peter where do ideas come from
and how do they take hold in society
what's is that the nature of
collaboration is that the basic atom of
collaboration is ideas
it's not not ideas but it's not only
ideas there's a book i just started
reading called death from a distance
have you heard of this no it's a really
fascinating thesis which is that
humans are the only conspecific
the
the only species that can kill other
members of the species from range
and maybe there's a few exceptions but
if you look in the animal world you see
like pronghorns butting heads right you
see the alpha uh line and the beta lion
and they take each other down humans we
develop the ability to chuck rocks at
each other and while at prey but also at
each other and that means the beta male
can chunk a rock at the alpha male and
take them down
and with very he can throw a lot of
rocks actually miss a bunch of times so
just hit once and be good so
um this ability to actually kill members
of our own species from range without a
threat of harm to ourselves
created essentially mutually assured
destruction where we had to evolve
cooperation if we didn't
then if we just continue to try to do
like i'm the the biggest monkey in the
tribe and i'm gonna you know
own this tribe and you have to go
if we do it that way then those tribes
basically failed and the tribes that's
that persisted and that have now given
rise to the modern homo sapiens are the
ones where respecting the fact that we
can kill each other from range
uh without heart like there's an
asymmetric ability to to snipe the
leader from range
that
meant that we sort of had to learn how
to cooperate with each other right come
back here don't throw that rock at me
let's talk our witnesses out so violence
is also part of collaboration the threat
of violence let's say
well the recognition i was maybe the
better way to put it is the recognition
that we have more to gain by working
together
than the prisoner's dilemma
of both of us defecting
so uh mutually assured destruction in
all his forms is part of this idea of
collaboration well and eric weinstein
talks about our nuclear piece right i
mean it kind of sucks with thousands of
warheads aimed at each other in russia
and the us but it's like on the other
hand
you know we only fought proxy wars right
we did not have another world war three
of like hundreds of millions of people
dying to like machine gun fire and and
you know giant you know guided missiles
so the original nuclear weapon is a rock
that we learned how to throw essentially
the original yeah well the original
scope of the world for any human being
was their little tribe
i would say it still is to the most for
the most part
you